welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and marvel's eternals is
introducing us to characters hidden on
earth the whole time
and they've been doing a bang-up job
protecting this planet
we have watched
unguided we have helped them
progress
[Music]
and seen them accomplish
wonders yeah nailed it the eternal's
absence remains the biggest question
going into this film especially since
their apparent knowledge of captain
rogers back to his days in the 40s
makes it clear they weren't just
sleeping for the past century
so what's really going on here marvel
studios deeper agenda with this eternals
film might be to open us up to the truth
that all kinds
of beings were living in secret on this
planet the whole time
beings like the mutants don't go don't
go i swear this isn't going to be like
one division where we all thought
happened peters was quicksilver and m
stood for magneto instead of
my name's boner honestly big x-men names
like that
and crossovers with the same actors from
the fox films that's probably not the
way kevin feige's gonna go with his
reboot of these characters really the
first and only time he's discussed x-men
in the mcu was at comic-con back in 2019
and he deliberately used the term
mutants
not x-men there's no time left to talk
about mutants
and i think we can read that as a signal
that feige's x-men plan
is really a mutant plan three x-men
pre-wolverine
to properly establish mutant kind in the
mcu
from its origin point and i've long
believed that eternals is the perfect
place for that backstory and now this
trailer gave us a few clues indicating
that could be the direction they're
going the first is this mysterious
volcanic eruption
shown only briefly but if you go through
it frame by frame you can see a flash of
gold and a flash of violet white
and then a plume of smoke suddenly
disappearing almost as if
some of the eternals may have been in
the heat of this eruption
trying to bottle it up or that other
forces may have been in the midst of a
kind of battle during this
and then another shot shows the eternal
sprite crying while standing on a
lava-covered terrain like she's mourning
some civilization
the eternals were unable to save from
this seismic destruction
while some are wondering if this volcano
could be the eruption of mount vesuvius
as shown in loki
i'm not so sure because those volcanoes
are clearly different shapes
i think this could be part of the great
cataclysm
a disaster in an ancient war that
involved the atlanteans the deviants and
the celestials the kingdom of atlantis
and marvel lore once a land-based
kingdom
was attacked by forces of the deviant
empire
and to stave off the deviants the rulers
of atlantis opened up the magma pits
beneath the city
but doing so ended up rocking the entire
continent with earthquakes and volcanic
eruptions meanwhile the deviants were
also attacking the second host of
celestials and the celestials are like
what so the celestials retaliated by
causing a nuclear cataclysm on the
planet's surface which ended up sinking
both the deviant-controlled kingdom of
lemuria and the kingdom of atlantis
both of them plunging into the ocean now
in the past mcu we have gotten at some
hints at these kingdoms existences iron
man 2
featured a map with markers for future
marvel locations like wakanda
as well as some marker in the south
atlantic still yet to be identified now
the eternal's film was shot on the
canary islands just off the west coast
of africa
not far from that marker so they may
have been trying to go for some
geographic similarity there
so sprite in this moment could be
reacting to the volcanic destruction of
either atlantis or lemuria
in this great cataclysm as these land
masses are sinking into the ocean well
what does this have to do with mutants
i'm getting there
the character of namor the submariner so
namor is considered to be marvel's first
mutant technically
as part of the golden age era lineup
with captain america
and phineas horton a name that actually
appeared in the mcu
alongside howard stark's expo that would
be a point of history that i've
theorized
the eternal fastos could have been
supplying howard stark with the
vibranium for cap shield maybe why that
shield shows up so much in the trailer
but before i continue thanks to bang
energy for sponsoring this video
every can of bang has zero calories zero
carbs zero sugar and zero artificial
colors
each 16 ounce can contains 300
milligrams of caffeine super creatine
coq10 and branched chain amino acids i'm
sipping on birthday cake bash which i
feel like i deserve because i had to
spend two birthdays in a row away from
all my friends
there's always next here really i drink
a can of bang whenever i need to pick me
up in the morning or when i need to plow
through a long video and i want my mind
to be alert
or when i want to take a bite of
birthday cake but not have the cakey
texture of it so check out bang on
instagram you can get 10
off your order at bangenergy.com when
you use the code new rockstars 10. there
you can buy a variety pack of bang
energy or grab a 12 pack of your
favorite like peach mango lemon drop
rainbow unicorn if you're feeling
mystical use that code to rockstar's 10
and receive 10 off your order of bang
energy that's code new rock stars 10 for
10
off
now the trailer also shows cersei
handing a dagger to some mystery figure
a dagger that actually looks like it was
inspired by the ceremonial golden dagger
found in the royal tombs of ur the
sumerian port city in ancient
mesopotamia that dagger could have been
a token of loyalty
from the eternals to the people of
atlantis and i love the idea of namor
later fashioning this
into the pointed end of his spear now
kit harrington is playing dane whitman
black knight who wields the ebony blade
a weapon that was actually briefly
wielded by namor in the comics so
another way namor could be tied into
this new history there was that line in
avengers end game about
undersea earthquakes that okoye told
natasha to not worry about
did you get a reading on those tremors
it was a mild subduction under the
african plate
do we have a visual how are we handling
it not
it's an earthquake under the ocean we
handle it
by not handling it perhaps the ancient
rivalry between atlantis and the
deviants of lemuria has rekindled and
wakanda
itself a kingdom with ancient history
knows all about it and wants to keep it
a secret from all the other powers of
the planet but while namor may be
marvel's first mutant by publishing date
chronologically the first or at least
one of the earliest mutants
on earth was in savannah better known as
the x-men villain
apocalypse and we know this eternals
film is visiting several regions of the
world throughout history from ancient
mesopotamia to what looks like the
spanish conquest of mesoamerica
to ancient egypt and assuming we
actually get to see the creation process
of the eternals by the celestials it
seems likely the origins of humankind
and
mutant kind will also be explored since
the history of
all of these is connected in marvel lore
back to the celestials the dna imagery
in the eternals trailer might be
pointing to this genetic history
and we know from one division that wanda
maximov had some kind of genetic
predisposition before her exposure to
infinity stone radiation because she was
able to cast
low level probability x's as a young
girl before she ever came into contact
with the mind stone
so individuals with a mutant gene
still seem to exist in the mcu and
eternals could be the movie that
clarifies how
all of that began so really the mutant
plan may be
explaining the origins of this world and
the societies that live on it and how
some of those people are just mutants so
that kind of opens the door to us
understanding how mutants show up
everywhere in the future as opposed to
starting with the story of one
particular mutant because we already
really saw that in the fox films so
again it's probably too soon for a full
x-men lineup right now in the mcu but
eternals could
establish the mcu as a world in which
mutants have always existed
and then getting us going on a desperate
search for where the first mutant of the
modern age will appear
so let me know your thoughts on this
theory and to support this channel check
out one of our many great merch options
at nrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos follow me
rockstar subscribe to
rockstars for more analysis and
breakdowns of everything marvel
thank you for watching bye
[Music]
you